across the river is an area the
ukrainian army called the gray zone
neither ukrainian soldiers nor the
russian-backed separatists control the
area
the army says separatists shelled the
bridge a few days ago
ukrainian soldiers guard the riverbank
they shelled it using roughly 122
caliber weapons we were luckily
sheltering undercover at the time
in the distance i can hear what sounds
like heavy artillery and machine gun
fire
the ukrainian government has in the last
hour or so declared a state of emergency
now i remember being here in april there
was a man fishing at exactly this spot
and the bridge was a vital connection
point for people living in the gray zone
who used to come to this village to shop
to buy medicine and some of the children
used to go to school here but that's
simply not possible anymore
close by 46 year old katya unloads a
delivery of wood
her brother and sister live across the
front line in separatist control donetsk
there my family should shoot them over
the men are being conscripted there and
they are being conscripted here what
nonsense this is the 21st century and
look at us running around with guns
we are torturing each other
despite the risk 27 year old michael
still goes to the river to fish
he was injured in a car accident in 2013
the war started a year later and he
hasn't been able to get the
physiotherapy he needs since then
we have shelling every day you can hear
it now i've just come down to check that
it hasn't scared the fish away
this is one of a number of destroyed
homes in the village
70 year old svetlana whose home was
damaged by shelling in december
describes what some nights are like
the fireballs this big fly over our
houses they pass our windows lighting
the room the explosions are so loud
on the drive home
sudden and terrifying blasts
hidden ukrainian artillery fires shells
towards separatist held territory
what the ukrainian army say is defensive
action against the russian-backed threat
just over the hills
charles stratford al jazeera granite
eastern ukraine
well joining us now from moscow is
tatiana kukareva deputy head of news uh
from uh sputnik news in russia thanks
very much for being with us so um
i don't know if you've been hearing uh
some of the uh comments that have been
made at the united nations
uh today but uh with the exception of
the uh the russian um ambassador most of
the uh uh speeches have been very much
um
criticizing russia and saying this is
all this is all on russia here and that
they are the aggressor
and that this is this is a conflict of
their choosing what do you say to that
good evening hasan
well obviously uh those comments come
from the same countries that have been
supplying military aid and financial aid
to ukraine all these years
the same countries
some of which actually were supposed to
guarantee
that there is no violence in the
donation
republics
you know the minsk agreements that
that were
uh you know agreed upon in in 2015
uh and that was supposed to
actually be observed and they never were
at least the ukrainian side never pulled
back troops they never stopped the
shelling
and of course the west you know those
countries the same countries that
supplied
billions and and aid
in military aid some in lethal aid i
believe it was just germany that
actually refused to supply weapons
to ukraine whereas the united states
has contributed immensely to
ukraine's military there's also you know
this undisclosed number of u.s military
personnel
that is right now training ukraine's
military uh although technically and
that's uh you know what president putin
um spoke about in his address uh
back when he
you know announced the recognition of
the two republics of their independence
any presence of foreign military troops
on ukrainian soil actually contradicts
the ukrainian constitution
and yet all of that
where is that where is their presence
where is the presence of foreign troops
in ukraine right now
well look it's uh it depends on how you
look at it right uh because if you're
saying it's sending in military the
foreign troops are either there or
they're not so
where where are you saying the foreign
troops are in
ukraine i'm saying that there are
military advisers so-called military
advisers from u.s in ukraine
but of course this situation all of this
information there's their stationments
are obviously classified as is the
number of those military advisors
where are you getting this information
that there are foreign military advisers
in ukraine because that's not the the uh
that we haven't seen any reports that
say that at all
the the us has been sending in military
advisors
yes
well that's how is that that was
actually
uh
i'm not gonna you know obviously i can't
say that uh you know i can't quote just
quote my president but those are very
actual real reports you know you can
google them
there are us military advisors and there
have been all these years in ukraine
now you say that this the
russia russia is reacting to what
ukraine has done and you mentioned the
minsk agreements there but most
independent observers say that the
language in the minsk agreements is very
vague in terms of what kind of
governance there can be
uh in those territories and the
ukrainians have argued that it is russia
and the separatists that have uh
consistently uh violated those terms
what do you say to that
well we can we can argue about the
governance and the the the language but
the terms of the minsk agreements were
actually very concrete and they involved
pulling back heavy artillery from the
separation line
that's number one the number one point
that was never observed from the
ukrainian side
but the ukrainians again have said that
they are simply responding to uh russian
uh provocations on this
but yes they are but they're also they
also never provide any proof of said
provocations and again you know if we're
talking about a pullback of heavy
artillery
what is an answer to
if you're not pulling back your heavy
artillery what are you answering to what
kind of provocations
you mentioned you you referred to uh
president putin's speech a couple of
days ago in that speech
he made some some comments about uh how
he saw
ukraine's origins and he said that uh
ukraine was essentially a country uh
created uh out of out of uh russia
how would uh the millions of you
ukrainians
feel about that
well you'd have to ask the ukrainians uh
i guess but should they have a saying
in whether or not uh uh they they uh
say in their self-determination um uh
and not not the words of of one
but but we have to understand that if
those millions of ukrainians have
actually studied their history they
would not argue for the fact that
ukraine was in fact created with the
collapse of the soviet union it was part
of the soviet union which in turn you
know it kind of we can't say that
that was that was back in 1991 we're now
in 2022 so
um how do you how do you how do you
square those two things
well that is history is history you
can't rewrite it you can't change it and
despite the fact that you doesn't what
you say you say you can't rewrite
history isn't that what isn't that what
president putin is trying to do now
how so
well you tell me he's merely state that
ukraine was created when soviet union
fell apart and that it was a very uh you
know
there were some very creative decisions
at that time and regions that were
completely russian spoken
including the donetsk and lugansk
regents that at the time of uh even
before the unrest i believe the
the data even from back in the beginning
of the 2000s
stated that 80 percent of the population
of these regions considered themselves
to be russian spoken and
to to have russian as their native
language the language that ukraine
actually made it was a state language in
ukraine one of the two and then they
just you know they just canceled that
status
all right we're gonna have to
how do you feel
there
we're gonna have to leave it there uh
thanks very much for your time tatyana
kukareva joining us there from moscow
good evening to you